[Music]
on this Tuesday night driving the
message home to stay home don't even go
to national parks pretty much anything
with a door will be closed
the feds issue vital reminders share be
kind ask how you can help why Ottawa
hasn't invoked its federal powers over
nineteen and your cash the changes
coming to e aí and filing your taxes
multi-billion dollar bailout I felt it
was a pandemic long before was called a
pandemic Washington's promise to every
American plus the push for more tests
more ventilators and more supplies for
medical workers
[Music]
global national with Donna freezing
reporting tonight
Robin Gill as much as possible stay home
don't go out unless you absolutely have
to an extraordinary plea from Canada's
Prime Minister to work together by
staying home to help slow the spread of
Kovan 19 good evening and thank you for
joining us across the country tougher
measures are coming into force as
communities face the growing threat of
the pandemic kovat 19 constitutes a
danger of major proportions
we must act decisively we must not delay
that's Ontario Premier Doug Ford today
declaring a state of emergency and BC
and Alberta have declared a public
health emergency in Ontario and Alberta
gatherings of more than 50 people are
banned in Ontario restaurants and bars
have been told to shut down the move
comes after Ontario's first death from
the virus the man in his 70s from berry
BC announced three new deaths today that
brings the total number of deaths in
Canada to eight in terms of total
infections the situation is changing
quickly over the last week the number of
cases has grown steadily in Canada and
it continued to climb today as of
tonight there are more than 570 cases in
Canada including those who have
recovered BC reported a major spike
today 83 new cases bringing the total to
186 the other provinces with the most
cases are Ontario Alberta and Quebec the
sixth other Canadian provinces have all
detected the virus the prime minister
says his government is considering
emergency measures to better tackle the
pandemic for now he's asking Canadians
to do their part by staying home Mike
Armstrong has tonight's top story
there is no question what the Prime
Minister is trying to convey a delicate
balance of calm and concern the
country's health care system at this
point he says is strained but strong
whether you're a doctor or a nurse a
hospital administrator or maintenance
staff
you are doing an incredible job this is
a stressful time for everyone there may
also understandably be some strain on
politicians it wasn't hard to hear the
emotion and the voice of the Federal
Health Minister as she appealed to
Canadians to help each other make sure
that you're kind to one another check in
with vulnerable people by phone think of
ways you can help to ensure that we get
through this together
the main focus continues to be on
flattening the curve cutting down on
transmission to keep people home as of
tomorrow the federal government is
shutting down all national parks and all
heritage sites what this means for our
parks is that pretty much anything with
a door will be closed the issue of the
door into Canada is still being debated
Ottawa is closing the border to most of
the world effective just after midnight
but not to Americans the Deputy Prime
Minister says the border is a lifeline
to both countries moving Goods medicine
and workers but she's heard the
criticisms we're very aware that the
situation for British Columbia is
particularly acute and I had a long
conversation with premier Horgan about
it last night we we have to slow down
the spread of covet 19 the Premier of
Ontario is declaring an official state
of emergency much as the province is
shutting down nearly everything other
than grocery stores and pharmacies and
restaurants that do takeout or delivery
Ottawa isn't going quite that far it has
not enacted the Emergencies Act yet it
is a very serious step three different
federal ministers referred to x' day to
the emergencies act as a quote last
resort saying they hope we don't reach
the point where it's needed Mike
Armstrong Global News Ottawa Canada's
emergencies Act would allow the federal
government to declare a public welfare
emergency and that would give the
government sweeping power to lead a
national response to the outbreak like
restricting the movement of people
regulating how goods and services are
distributed it also allows the
government to set up emergency shelters
and hospitals it was formerly known as
the war Measures Act and was used during
the two world wars including to censor
newspapers and religious
Prime Minister Pierre Trudeau last
invoked it during the 1970 act Ober
crisis were members of the fontanelle
Hassan du Quebec
kidnapped the provinces deputy premier
and a British diplomat the federal
government is expected to unveil an
emergency stimulus package tomorrow to
help Canadians get by and keep the
economy afloat Global News has learned
key details my spring and globals
Michael Couture in Ottawa Mike what are
you hearing yeah Robin we have learned
that the economic stimulus package
presented by the government Wednesday
will be worth between 20 and 30 billion
dollars it's a massive figure that gives
us an idea of how significant the
government thinks the overall need could
be and perhaps how long Canadians will
require financial support now the
announcement will be made by the prime
minister and then additional details
will be laid out by the Finance Minister
Bill Morneau Justin Trudeau has been
leading meetings with key cabinet
ministers for the past few days in order
to come up with this plan we're also
hearing that the deadline for filing
your income tax returns will be extended
by one month meaning you'll now have
until June 1st no businesses are also
being given an extra month so their
deadline will be July 31st but some
business owners that we spoke to today
worry they won't survive if more
sweeping measures aren't brought in by
all levels of government
Lindsey Thompson and Jonathan Boni have
run the King Eddy in Ottawa for five
years there's been a lot of ups and
downs in that time but this is nearly
rock-bottom obviously our biggest fear
right now is just maintaining a
clientele you know paying the bills you
know being able to keep the virtual
doors open so to speak virtual doors
because the province of Ontario is
closing all dine in restaurants and bars
only takeout and delivery are allowed
which means waitstaff will be scaled
back obviously we are anticipating that
this would you know be inevitable so at
least now today we can go forward and
inform our staff what what what this
means Ontario Premier Doug Ford new
workers could be severely impacted by
his decision to close bars and
restaurants across the province while
his government is putting together a
financial stimulus package Ford is
leading a chorus of premiers urging the
federal government to step up and help
workers it's essential the federal
government gets moving on the EEI
instant
eeew I for four people that have been
laid off and if the federal plan isn't
finalized yet DC's premier has some
suggestions they need to make sure that
they're not shortchanging people in this
crisis it's a go big or go home
environment it seems to me a BC premier
John Horgan says he's confident the
Prime Minister understands that but he
says there is a sense of urgency now
because his government can't make a move
on worker compensation until he knows
what the federal government is doing
Robin my clicker tour in Ottawa thanks
Mike the Canadian Army is canceling its
largest training exercise of the year
due to Cova 19 exercise maple resolve is
now off so the military can protect
troops from the new coronavirus and keep
them ready to conduct operations when
required the exercise was scheduled to
be held in Wainwright Alberta in May and
was planned to prepare troops for
deployment to the Canadian leg NATO
mission in Latvia and Ukraine armed
forces in Wainwright live and work in
extremely close quarters in the US the
number of confirmed cases of Cova 19 is
climbing as more testing which was
initially limited is carried out over
5,000 people are infected right
now the white house is weighing a
massive emergency rescue package which
could see Americans receive cash
payments within two weeks to combat the
economic cost of the outbreak
Jackson prosecco reports seven million
California residents awoke to their
first day under lockdown told to stay
home and shelter in place while
America's largest city New York weighed
similar measures as daily life continued
to fade from view with empty streets
bars restaurants and businesses closed
can imagine everyone that works here
depended on this job and normal may not
return anytime soon the governor of New
York issued a dire warning that kovat 19
cases likely won't peak for at least 45
days overwhelming the medical system
they are expecting as many as 55,000 to
110,000 hospital beds will be needed as
states called for a coordinated federal
response the president struck a more
determined tone and walked back his
earlier attempts to downplay the
seriousness of the virus this is a
pandemic I felt it was a pandemic long
before it was called a pandemic the
White House is promising a massive
economic recovery package bailing out
airlines hotels and businesses and
offering assistance to every person in
the US we're looking at sending checks
to Americans immediately amidst the
crisis some states are pressing ahead
with business as usual large states like
Florida and Illinois pushed ahead with
voting in the presidential primaries
fearing there may not be a better time
to hold them Jackson Prosecco Global
News Washington
Canada is testing for köppen 19 more
widely than many countries around the
world including the US but now according
to the BC Centre for Disease Control BC
is facing a limited supply of swabs used
to test for the virus it's a critical
tool in the fight against the pandemic
as Eric Sorenson reports the results
give health officials crucial
information about the behavior of the
virus
at the height of the kovat 19 outbreak
in China it's now believed most cases
were missed those with milder symptoms
may have stayed home and were not tested
other countries are at that stage now a
new study suggests for every confirmed
case five to ten go undetected and that
mild cases are responsible for spreading
the majority of new cases it's why the
World Health Organization is emphasizing
the need to know who has the virus we
have a simple message for all countries
test test test
the high standard is South Korea which
tested almost 3,700 per 1 million
citizens and has limited the spread of
the virus Italy started late and has
tested just 826 per 1 million last week
at the low end the United States by last
week had only tested 23 per 1 million
Americans which could mean numbers there
are mushrooming undetected in this
country a jump in testing to almost 37
thousand now or about 982 per 1 million
Canadians there have been cases in
Canada where people with symptoms were
not tested because there was no foreign
travel or contact involved travel
history being a major risk is becoming
less and less relevant given that we
have clear local transmission going on
here in Canada as part of a 300 million
dollar relief fund Ontario plans to
expand testing we're backing up our
frontline public health workers with
more resources for monitoring and
testing experts say diagnostic centers
can do more tests while not over
burdening hospitals I think that's
really important because we probably
will be seeing increased case numbers at
the hospital and if we can do anything
possible to keep people that just aren't
sick enough to be in hospital out of the
hospital we're doing something right
more testing may cause Kovan 19 numbers
to spike but it will also paint a more
accurate picture of the crisis in this
country
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto it's
the first day of a nationwide lockdown
in France that country has nearly
seventy seven hundred cases of Kovan 19
people are only allowed to leave their
homes for specific reasons like medical
needs shopping for groceries
or essential work a hundred thousand
police officers are patrolling in Italy
and Spain the situation is growing more
grave the total number of people with
Coppa 19 in Spain has jumped by nearly
2,000 new cases in a single day to more
than 11,000 cases italy has nearly
tripled the number of cases with more
than 31,000 2,500 people have died
coming up
fears Canadian hospitals don't have
enough ventilators
for those critically ill with kovat 19
ventilators are the difference between
life and death several provinces have
ordered more but as Heather York's West
reports there are concerns suppliers
won't be able to keep up with the
soaring demand we're ordering and we are
taking all the strategies in Quebec
provincial health officials offered
reassurance Tuesday that if patient
demand on hospitals were to rise because
of kovat 19 the medical system would not
be short supplies we are really having a
lot of the help from companies and so I
want to reassure that we should have
what we need across the country health
systems are looking at how to expand
capacity particularly in intensive care
Italy has seen demand for critical care
beds sore and with them the need for
ventilators health experts warn that if
countries are unprepared people will die
certainly in the more worst-case
scenarios it could mean things like
triage decisions around who gets a
ventilator based on who is more likely
to recover several provinces have
additional ventilators on order Manitoba
is awaiting 20 Alberta 50 while Nova
Scotia has ordered a hundred and 40 new
units a number that would increase its
supply by 60%
but Canadian hospitals will need to
compete for these resources with a
growing global demand and suppliers have
warned they may not be able to keep up
it's why the British government has
reached out to companies like Ford Honda
and rolls-royce to help make health
equipment Canada's federal government is
looking for help as well
the Canadian Chamber of Commerce CEO
tweeting Tuesday
are you a manufacturer who can retool to
manufacturer critical medical equipment
if yes the federal government wants to
hear from you we need to mobilize all of
the resources that we have in Canada to
be able to respond effectively they so
far certainly what I've been hearing
from members of the business community
is that where they have the capacity to
do so they're glad to make their
contribution wartime like efforts in the
global fight against kovat 19 Heather
Eric's West Global News Calgary still
ahead can Canada's medical supplies keep
up
the new coronavirus has brought with it
a desperate need for medical supplies
like gloves and face masks to keep
canadians but especially frontline
health care workers who are extremely
vulnerable safe from contracting Cova 19
tonight our Ross Lord looks at how
prepared Canada's health care system is
and whether it has enough resources to
cope this how-to video for Nova Scotia
health care workers is aimed at
simplifying personal protective
equipment now you've got your gown on
and you've got your facial protection
off the next video from the same Health
Authority is troubling protective
equipment is going missing from Nova
Scotia hospitals at an alarming rate and
what that means is that people are
taking masks and other protective
equipment out of the organization there
are similar reports from other provinces
and the timing could not be worse masks
and gowns can keep coworkers from
catching covered 19 from their patients
a possible source of infection in the
case of a care worker at North
Vancouver's Linn Valley care center the
federal government says it's pursuing
suppliers of everything from masks and
gloves to laundry services and IT
support as well of course we're reading
all those systems that we've talked
about the laboratory systems the
surveillance systems protecting our
health workers very important the World
Health Organization admits there's a
global shortage of protective equipment
that's leaving doctors and nurses
dangerously ill equipped but provinces
prefer reassurance and we're purchasing
more personal protective equipment like
masks gloves surgical gowns for our
nurses doctors and personal support
workers as well as more ventilators a
National Union for nurses says it's not
enough insisting members need more say
in their level of protection because
methods like social distancing don't
apply have you ever seen a nurse or a
health care worker do a treatment with
over two meters we're very very close
it's easier to agree on this point for a
country in uncharted territory providing
enough safeguards
and using them properly will be a
challenge Ross Lord global news Halifax
can you get Cova 19 more than once
up next experts answer your questions
coping with this pandemic is very
stressful for many Canadians and it
shows no signs of slowing down
there are a lot of questions around Copa
19 and you've sent many of them to us
our Jeff simple has gone to the experts
to get some answers
Jeff social distancing is a big topic of
discussion what are people saying well
Robin by now Canadians have heard the
warnings to avoid large gatherings so no
sporting events concerts or Saint
Patrick's Day parades but what about the
smaller stuff hi my name is Jason Miller
I'm from Edmonton Alberta we're having a
bit of an argument in our household my
wife doesn't want us to go anywhere she
doesn't want her our kids to go out to
visit friends to go to the gym obviously
that's closed now but I'd be curious to
know what your thoughts are on that
we've been told time and time again
don't congregate avoid the places where
people congregate work from home you
know schools if you cancel the NHL has
been canceled I mean like what more
signals people need and speaking of
keeping your distance we've all seen
those images of shoppers crowding stores
and stockpiling supplies that's prompted
one viewer to write noting this seems
like the perfect setting to increase the
numbers of people contracting this
disease should the stores limit the
number of customers going in to shop the
answer yes Costco and shoppers Drug Mart
are among the retailers now taking
extraordinary steps to limit the number
of customers allowed in the store and
the quantity of supplies they can
purchase at one time hey Jeff this is
Ken Martin in st. John's Newfoundland
and Labrador wondering if you could ask
your your medical experts to talk a
little bit about the good news in the
step stats the people who are recovering
people having mild symptoms there have
been around two hundred thousand
reported cases of kovat 19 worldwide
nearly half of those have already
recovered
the vast majority of cases the symptoms
were relatively mild and manageable as
long as it's mild and it's going away
camp out at home for 14 days wait for it
to pass and then hopefully you've had
this another viewer emailed us to ask if
someone gets the virus and then recovers
can that person become infected again we
don't know the answer to that yet those
experts admit that the answer to many of
these questions is that they still don't
know this outbreak is still in the early
stages as one of them put it we're now
at the end of the beginning
Robin Jeff sample in Toronto thanks Jeff
we know you have lots of questions about
this virus Jeff we'll continue to
consult with experts and try to answer
them so email your questions at global
news dot CA on our website you'll find a
special page dedicated entirely to the
new corona virus that's at Global News
CA slash coronavirus that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Robin Gill
tonight we're looking at new ways to
celebrate Saint Patrick's Day
bells rang out over empty churches
across Ireland sending up messages of
Hope parades were canceled but virtual
ones kept spirits high thank you for
watching and I'll see you back here
tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]